♪ ♪
>> Tucker: S IMODERN
AMERICA IF YOU PNT O THAT
BIOLICAL SEX IS AHYSICAL
REALY YOU CAN BE FIRED FROM
UR J.
"THEASHINGTON POSTWILLEND
A REPORTER TO YOUR USE TORY
TO IIMIDATE YOU BUT IT DOES
NO CHANGE ANYTHG, DENYINGREALIT,
U CA SAY GRAVITY I NOT REAL
BUT IFOU JPFF THE ROOF OF
YOUR GARAG WERE STILL GETTI
HURT.
THAT IBIOLOGICAL SEX.
OFFICIAL IN NEWERSEY ARE
LEARNING TT THISEEK.
TWO FEME INMATES AT A
SUPPOSEDLY ALLEMALE PRENT
HAVEECOME PREGNAN WONDER HOW
THATAPPENED.
TURNS OUT THOSEOMEN HAD
SEXUAL ENCOUNTERS WI OTHER
INMATE WHO IS A
BIOLOGAL M INASSING AS A
MAN.
SOMEEOPLE PREDICTETHIS WOULD
HAPPEN ANDHEY WE LAUGHED AT,
MOED,ND ATTACKED AS BIGOTS.
ATHE TOP OF THAT LIST, SHE
SAID THIYEARS GO O OURHOW,
SHE  THE PRESIDENT OF THE
U.S. CHAPTER OF T WOMEN'S
CLARATION OF INTERNAONAL,
AUTHOR OF THE BK "THE
ABITION OF SEX:OW THE
AND GIRLS" A WE'RE HAPPY TOHAVEC
ANKS SO MUCH FOR CING ON.
TIME, AND HAD TO BE  LST
FOUR YRS A, WN YOU SAID IF
ARE GOINGO HAV BIOLOGIL MEN
INOMEN'S PRISONS, AND Y WERE
RIGHT.
>> ABSOLUTY,HANK YOU SO MUC
FOR HAVI ME.
THE ORYHAT IS HAPPENING IN
W JERSEY IS OBVIOUS HORRIE
FOR SO MAN REASONS.
WE NEETO N HE MENEING
HOED IWOMEN'S PRISO, BUT A
UPLE TAKEAWAYS FROM THIS AT
I JUST WAN TO POINT O, FIRST
OF ALLHE STE IS NOT GETTING
AWAY WITH THISY TELNG ITS
REDENTS THAT THE ARE HOUSI
N AND WOMEN'SRISO.
WHAT THEY A DOING, OF COUR,
ISELLING THE RIDENTS THEY
ARE HOUSING -CALLED
TRANENDER WOMEN OR TRANS WOMEN
IN WEN'S PRISONS, SUGGESTING
ERE IS SOME SORTFSUBCATEGY OWOMD
TRANS WOMEN, A IT IS NOT TRUE.
THE FACT THATHIS STOSHOOTS -- ST
TRANS WOME ARE WOM.OUROCIETY HAT
WE A SUPSED TO SAY ANDHINK
THAT TRANSOMEN AREOMEN, BUTOBVI,
CAUSE THE INDIVIDLS THAT ARE
THE FOCUS O THIS STORY
IMPREGTED WOMEN, AND EVERY
THINKING ADU, NO MATR WHAT
E PRESIDENT OFHE
UNITEDTATES HAS TO SAY ON EMATT
TEGO OF WOMEN WHOAN
IMPREGTE WEN.
SO I REALLYANT TOHANK YOU
R HIGHLIGHTINTHIS STORY, AND
ALSO JUST WAN TO POINT OUT,
TH IS T JUST A PROBL IN
NEW RSEY.
TH IS A PROBLEMCROSS THE
UNTRY.
I KN WE HAVE TKED EVIOUSLY
ABOUT HOW THE STE OF
CALIFORNIA RECTLY ENACTED A
LAW AT THE END OF 2020 WHICH
NT INTO EFFEC IN 2021, WHICH
NDAT THAT MEN B HOUD IN
WOMEN'S PRINS ON THE BIS O
THR SO-CALLED GENR IDENTIT
IF THEYAY THE ARE WOMEN.
SHINGTON STATE HAS A SIMILAR
POLICY.
HOWEVER, TS I NOT JUST
HAPPENINGN BLUE STATES, THIS
ISAPPENING ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AS FAR AS I KNOW, 49 STAT PLUS
TH DTRICT OF COLUMBIA HAVE
SO FORM OFAW OR POLICYN
PLACE THAT MANTES THEOUSING
OFEN IN WOMEN'S ISON
>> Tucker: WHY IST LEFTO
YOU D J.K. ROWLING OUT A
COLE OF OTHERS TO PNT THIS
T?
ERE ARE THE PHYSICIANSHO
KNOW PFECTLY WELL TT WH
YOU'RE SAYIN IS TRUE, TT
BIOLOGISTSNOW IT EVERY BIT,S
WELL, WHY ARE TY GOING ALONG
WITH THIS WN THEY KNOW ITS A
LI
>>O THE EIRE MEDICAL
ESTABLISHMT IN THEUNITED STES SE
BY SO-CALL TRANSDEOLOGY, AND
WHAT I REALLYANT ALLMERINS
ROSS THE POLITICAL SCTRUM TO
UNDERSTAND IS THAT TRANSSOTA CIT
PROTECA MARGINALID COMMUNITY
OF PEOPLE, IT IS A MULTRILLION
DOLL INDTRY THAT IS PUSHING
IS.
IT IS PAYING T MEDICALESTABLISET
MEDIA OLETS IT IS PAYING OU
GOVERNMENT, IT ISAYING OUR
SCHOOL, A ALL LEVELS FROM
ELEMENTARYCHOOL THROUGH
COLLEGE, TO PH THEDEA AT
TERIALS --HE MERIAL
ALITY OF SEX DOES N EXIST,
AND THAT WHAT I ME IMPORTANT
THAN THEATERIAL REATY O SEX
ISO-CALLED GENDE IDENTITY.
IS IS ALL BEING PUSHE BY
MUITRILLIONOLLARNDUSTRY IN
THE GUISE OF SIMPLE RIGHTS
MOVENT.
IT IALLIE.
>> Tucker: THESE ARE THE
PEOPLE PVIDING OUR MEDICAL
RE, IT IS SCY --
>> TY ARE.
I KNOW SOMEONEHO I A MEDICAL
STUDENT RIGHT NOW AND SHE ISHORI
TAHT.
I  WANT TO SAY REAY QUICKLY,
THERE IS SOMHINGHAT HASEEN
ANUNCEIN THE PASTOUPLE OF
WEEKS CALLEDHE WOMEN'S
BILLF RIGHTS.
THIS WAS DRAED BY MEMBERS O
E WON'S LIBERATIO FRONT AND
BY MEMBERS OINDENDENTWOMEN'S VOR
AMERIC AND I REALLYOPE ONE
OF THEEMBERS OF CONGSS
INTRUCES IT.
THANK YOU S MUCH.
>> Tucr: I HOPE SO TOO.
GRT TO S Y